MICHAEL BALDWIN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Michael Baldwin.
I lead Financial Services
Product Management
for Google Cloud.
With me today is my
colleague Tom Thane, also
a financial services
product manager.
Thanks for joining us.
Tom and I both spend
our days thinking
about how we can help financial
institutions transform
their businesses with artificial
intelligence and machine
learning.
Today, we'll be sharing
with you an overview
of some of the
major areas where we
see this transformation
happening
and how Google Cloud can help.
We know that business
transformation
is top of mind for many of our
financial services customers.
However, these are
challenging times,
with financial services
institutions navigating
the pandemic.
Interest rates are
at an all-time low.
Customer expectations are
changing with the shift
to digital.
For example, digital banking
has increased from 63% in 2019
to 72% today.
Regulatory requirements
are evolving
and compliance costs
are increasing.
Also, the financial
services industry as a whole
is facing new and
creative types of fraud.
For example, the dollar
value of attempted
fraudulent transactions grew
35% in April year-over-year.
And finally, with
the move to digital,
disruption is accelerating.
For instance, the pandemic
drove a 72% increase
in the use of fintech
apps in Europe.
Today, we'll cover
three areas where
we see AI helping to unlock
business transformation
in financial services.
First, AI can help reimagine
the customer experience
to deliver things such as
personalized digital banking,
contact centers with a
AI-powered virtual agents,
and smoother customer
experiences for traditionally
paper-intensive
processes, like lending.
Second, financial institutions
are looking for ways
to use data and analytics
to transform how
they detect and manage risk.
And finally, financial
institutions ask us
for a best-in-class AI platform
that is flexible, secure,
and compliant,
that empowers them
to build their own
AI-powered solutions
to solve their most
critical business problems.
As we talk about
through examples
of AI-powered transformation
in financial services,
you'll see that AI isn't
a science experiment.
It's being used to solve
real-world problems
across banking, capital markets,
insurance, and payments.
The key thing for us is
working with our customers
to identify their top business
problems, then figuring out
how AI can be most helpful
for them in solving
for their key needs.
And ultimately, our goal is
to make it as easy as possible
to deploy these solutions
in real-world, end-to-end
workflows.
Deloitte recently surveyed
over 2,700 global IT
and line-of-business executives
to obtain a global view of how
organizations are adopting,
benefiting from, and managing
AI technologies.
And as you can see from this
recent Deloitte survey, shown
here on the slide,
81% of customers
are reporting payback on their
AI in less than two years.
When AI is absorbed
in this way, it
can lead to true
business transformation.
So first, let's talk about
how artificial intelligence
can help transform the
customer experience.
Customer experience is,
obviously, a broad area.
Let's talk through a few
examples of what this can mean.
Many financial
institutions today
struggle to get a single view
of the customer, sometimes known
as customer 360.
With the continued shift from
physical branches to digital,
financial institutions
are looking for new ways
to deliver high-quality and
helpful experiences across all
of their customer touch
points, lighting up
omnichannel operations across
web, mobile, contact centers,
physical branches, and ATMs.
When it comes to
acquiring new customers,
financial institutions want
to onboard in days, not weeks,
and are looking to use
AI-powered intelligence
to help retain those customers.
Finally, as customer
360 becomes a reality,
we'll be able to enable
AI-powered experiences
to sell the right product
to the right customer
at the right time,
and also drive
other personalized insights to
help with customer retention
and new business acquisition.
Our Contact Center AI
solution is one example
of how AI is helping reimagine
the customer experience.
First, let me share a quick
overview of our Contact Center
AI solution.
The goal of Contact Center AI is
to deliver exceptional customer
service and increase
operational efficiency
using artificial intelligence.
It enables virtual agents
to converse naturally
with customers and expertly
assist human agents
on complex cases.
It does this through a set of
underlying powerful features,
for example, Dialogflow, which
automates basic chat and voice
interactions, a feature
called Agent Assist,
which makes human
agents more effective,
and Insights, which unlocks
insights about call drivers
and customer service
interactions.
Customer support is particularly
relevant in financial services,
as financial institutions
have seen 1,000% increase
in call volume since the
onset of the pandemic.
Customers are calling
in with questions
like are branches still open?
Can I defer loan payments?
Are you waiving
any fees right now?
And, of course,
security is paramount
in financial services.
So our teams are hard
at work making sure
that we have bank-level security
built into this product.
Next, I want to share
how we're working
to make lending
more operationally
efficient and create smoother
customer experiences.
Our Lending Document AI alpha is
built on top of our Document AI
technology.
Document AI helps
organizations unlock insights
from their mountains
of documents using
artificial intelligence by
turning unstructured data
into structured data, which
means you can now actually
understand and utilize it.
With mortgage rates
low, there's a surge
in mortgage applications.
This solution provides a bundle
of specialized models, focused
on specific document
types used in lending.
And with this solution, we're
able to work with lenders
to quickly onboard
customers and speed up
the processing of
paper-intensive mortgage
applications.
Also, when the US Congress
authorized the Paycheck
Protection Program as part of
the pandemic relief package,
we made this same
technology available to help
with the processing
of PPP loans.
Next, let's talk
about insurance.
Dealing with a car
accident can be
a major headache for
the automobile owner
and a time-consuming
process for the insurer.
We worked with USAA, an insurer,
and a Google partner, Mitchell,
to build ML models
that analyze images
of cars that have
been in accidents
and make damaged
parts estimates.
This, in turn, can be converted
into an estimate of costs
needed to repair the car,
saving appraisers' time
and leading to smoother
customer experience.
Now I'm going to hand
things over to Tom Shane,
my colleague and fellow product
manager for financial services,
who will walk us through
how AI is driving business
transformation and
risk management,
and also will share an overview
of how our AI platform is being
used by developers
and data scientists
inside financial institutions
to deliver on their top business
priorities.
Over to you, Tom.
TOM SHANE: Thanks, Michael.
When Google Cloud
thinks about how
we can help apply AI
and ML to transform
financial services and
the risk management space,
we typically think
about four key things.
First is mitigating
risk across channels
and digital experiences.
As Michael said,
financial institutions
are increasingly looking to
move to a digital-first posture
in the post-COVID environment.
That provides great benefits
from a customer experience
perspective.
But it does open up new vectors
of risk and potential fraud,
for example, rising scams in
the retail banking segment.
Second, moving to holistic
and contextual analysis--
by holistic, we mean
extracting signals
from traditional
structured data sources,
but also combining that with
insights from unstructured data
to form one holistic
or customer 360 view.
That allows financial
services organizations
to contextually analyze
customers and events
and detect true
anomalies or risks that
need to be reviewed from normal
behavior for that customer
or event.
Third, thinking about how to
dynamically and rapidly respond
to changing risk types--
for example, changing
macroeconomic and market
conditions or new fraud types
in the post-COVID world.
And finally, being able to offer
that worry-free and seamless
customer experience--
customers want to know that the
risk management systems that
are operating in the background
are keeping their accounts
and assets safe,
but they don't want
those systems to inappropriately
impact the customer experience.
For example, a false positive
alert on a fraud transaction.
Next, I want to talk
about a customer who's
working to help transform their
risk management processes.
HSBC is working
with Google Cloud
to leverage the latest
in machine learning
to dynamically assess
potential financial crime risk
and holistically
look at customers.
HSBC is bringing their
extensive knowledge
of combating
financial crime, which
combined with Google's expertise
in developing ML solutions,
is already leading to
encouraging results
in this area.
You may have heard from our
CEO, Thomas Kurian's, keynote
that Google Cloud is
focused on building up
digital transformation solutions
powered by Google's AI.
In risk management,
we're focused
on giving you a preview of
two of those solutions today.
The first is anti-money
laundering, or AML,
and the second is know
your customer, or KYC.
I want to talk about some of
the challenges and opportunities
in each of these areas.
When our customers
ask us about AML,
they often talk about challenges
around the current rule-based
system, and that sophisticated
bad actors can sometimes
get around these systems,
leading to potential missed
money laundering events.
And the system often lead
to many false positives.
On the data side, we also hear
challenges about poor data
quality and the lack of that
holistic or customer 360 view
to inform their AML efforts.
And finally, we hear that
all of these false positives
are creating heavy amounts
of manual work, which
is taking away from
higher-value opportunities.
In terms of opportunities
for innovation,
Google Cloud can help
extract insights from data
and apply AI and ML technologies
to better detect and prevent
and identify those real
money laundering events,
and then help organizations
operate more efficiently
by reducing false positives, as
well as providing more insights
in the alert review process.
Know your customer, or
KYC, is another area
that financial institutions
often ask us about.
We hear challenges,
such as manual processes
around looking at
documents and combining
that with other information.
We hear how this sometimes
impacts the customer onboarding
process, either
delaying it or leading
to excessive
outreach to customers
to collect information.
And finally, we hear
about challenges
of integrating all
this information
into banks' overall systems.
We think there's three
key opportunities
to help improve this process.
The first is helping
in the automation part.
By automation, we
mean looking at all
of the documents received
in the KYC process
and automatically extracting
insights, entities,
and information from
these documents,
and putting them into
downstream processes.
We also think there's
an opportunity
to move to a rapid and digital
onboarding process, especially
important in the
post-COVID environment.
And finally, we think extracting
insights from these documents
can better identify potential
risk sooner, as well as inform
financial services
organizations' overall customer
360 efforts.
Next, I want to turn
to the capital markets
space and BNY
Mellon, who's using
machine learning to predict
treasury settlement failures.
The treasury market is one of
the largest and most liquid
in the world.
However, 1% to 2%
of transactions
fail every day, which
equates to about $70 billion.
So BNY Mellon is
leveraging Google Cloud
to develop end-to-end pipelines
to better predict when
these settlements might fail.
This has allowed
BNY Mellon to get
in front of these
potential failures
and help mitigate them
before the data cutoff.
Outside of solutions in the
customer experience and risk
management space, we also
know financial institutions
want to build
their own AI and ML
models for a range of different
use cases and business
problems.
So at Google Cloud,
we're focused
on building and deploying
a flexible platform
to allow financial services
organizations to build out
these models.
And this is based on
Google's learnings
running large-scale ML systems.
We believe that responsible
AI equals successful AI.
When we at Google think
about responsible AI,
we typically think
about four key pillars.
The first is robustness.
And that's making sure
results stay robust over time.
The second is ensuring
that these systems
are understandable.
The third is considering
the fairness implications
of these systems.
And the fourth is incorporating
security by design
to keep both the
data and the assets
secure throughout the
entire model lifecycle.
In terms of
robustness, at Google,
we found that transition into
end-to-end machine learning
pipelines greatly
helps in this way.
We see that an ML system is
much more than just a model.
It's about consistently
extracting and validating data,
ensuring the data distributions
don't shift over time.
It's about applying the right
features and the right model
to the problem, training the
model, evaluating the results,
and ultimately deploying
it to production.
A common failure mode that we
often hear from our customers
is a great model that
works well in development,
but can't transition
to production.
It doesn't replicate
results in production.
So we've introduced
AI Platform Pipelines,
which is coming soon, to
help with this problem.
AI Platform Pipelines
is integrated
with other GCP native
services, such as our data
warehouse, BigQuery, and our AI
serverless training platform.
We know that financial
institutions are also
focused on making sure ML
systems are understandable.
We know that this is key
in financial services
for a couple key
reasons, the first being
that these systems often
underpin high-value business
problems, where the
results need to be robust
and they need to
be understandable.
Third, these systems often
interact with humans,
whether it's in a model
governance approval process
or in downstream processes, such
as an analyst reviewing a fraud
alert.
And finally, we know
these models need
to meet regulatory obligations.
So Google has built our
explainable AI solution
based on Google's experience
understanding and interpreting
ML systems.
This solution provides
feature attributions
to say which attributes or
features are most predictive
of any given prediction?
In this hypothetical example
that you see in the lower
right-hand corner, you can
see that the amount, feature,
or attribute is most predictive
of this particular prediction.
Google is also very committed
to AI and ML fairness.
We've released
our AI principles,
which govern applications in
which Google applies its AI
and ML technology.
And we've also released
a fairness toolkit.
I want to highlight a
couple of components of it.
First is the what if
tool, which allows
organizations to dynamically
dissect their data and results.
The second is
fairness indicators,
which allows organizations
to provide categories
and then slice different
fairness performance
metrics by those categories
to evaluate differences
across groups.
And finally, I want to talk
about our responsible AI
practices to provide guidelines
to organizations implementing
these systems.
Next, I want to
talk about security
and how at Google Cloud,
we're incorporating this
by design in our AI
platform and solutions.
We know security is
absolutely table stakes
for a financial
services organization.
So we're focused
on a couple areas.
The first is preventing
data exfiltration
with our VPC Service
Controls and ensuring
no external internet access.
The second is providing choice.
So customers can use
their own encryption keys
to encrypt and decrypt data.
And customers can choose
where data processing happens
and where their data is stored
in terms of data residency.
And finally, always ensuring
authorized and appropriate
access to that data through
fine grain identity and access
management controls, as well as
our Access Transparency Logs.
Finally, I want to turn
to a customer who's
using Google Cloud's AI
and ML infrastructure.
Two Sigma has moved some of
their deep learning research
to the cloud, in
large part to leverage
the latest AI and
ML infrastructure.
They're using Google Cloud's
tensor processing units,
or TPUs, which are
purpose-built chips by Google
for machine learning
training and inference.
And you can see when Two
Sigma moved their TensorFlow
workloads to TPUs, they saw a
boost in productivity, which
allows them to spend
less time worrying
about managing their
AI and ML systems
and more time crafting results.
In summary, Google
Cloud is focused
on providing
data-powered innovation
in financial services.
We're building out
AI-powered solutions
in customer experience
and risk management
for financial services
organizations.
And we're also focused on
enabling a digital platform
to allow financial services
organizations to build
and deploy their own AI and
ML solutions in a way that
meets the requirements.
We look forward to
meeting you and working
with you help transform the
future of financial services.
If you're interested
in learning more,
please follow the
URL on the slide.
Thank you so much for
taking time out of your day.
And again, we look forward
to working with you.